et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Olivier fort bonjour
député de Seine-et-Marne premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Fabrice
wesseraudon du groupe Ebra bonjour
Fabrice bonjour Olivier
fort le président de la République qui
prendra donc la parole ce soir à 20h
est-ce que vous en attendez quelque
chose
je crois que le président a tout fait
pour qu'on attend de rien du tout de son
allocution il a tout fait pour que le
lien soit rompu il est face à un pays
qu'il a lui-même fracturé et on sait
bien qu'il est capable à l'oral de nous
faire les plus grands discours on se
souvient de ces discours pendant la
période du confinement mais ce sont
précisément ces femmes et ces hommes
qu'il a lui-même félicité applaudit
comme nous tous à 20h qui sont
aujourd'hui les principales victimes de
la réforme qu'il a engagée et donc
il pourra nous dire ce qu'il veut en
fait vous savez vous connaissez cette
formule sur l'amour en fait il y a pas
l'amour il y a des preuves d'amour et je
pense que le président a besoin de
donner des preuves au peuple français
qui les entend ce week-end j'étais en ma
circonscription
beaucoup marché avec les uns et les
autres et que j'ai entendu j'ai entendu
des gens qui se sentaient mépriser en
colère nous disons mais au fond le
président ne met qu'en application ce
qu'il a dit quand il était dans une gare
en expliquant qu'il y avait ces gens de
rien et ces gens qui m'ont parlé l'un
d'entre eux m'a dit je me sens
effectivement à ses yeux je ne suis rien
je ne suis rien du tout il n'écoute
jamais il n'est jamais capable
d'entendre ce que lui dit le peuple
français et nous en sommes là nous
sommes avec un président qui est isolé
et qui sait lui-même enlisée à l'Elysée
et qui voilà c'est un peu la quadature
du cercle tentent en termes de
communication qui sont le plan politique
est-ce qu'il faut qu'il communique qui
ne communique pas
la bonne solution
pour nous dire que il est très heureux
de ce qu'il a fait qu'il va continuer et
qu'on passe à la chose enfin qu'on passe
à la suite mais je crois qu'il n'a pas
compris il n'a pas compris qu'il n'y a
pas de suite possible sans revenir sur
la réforme des retraites il y a un
risque que ce soit contre-productif que
ce soit
je pense surtout que tout ce qu'il fait
est contre-productif il aurait pu ne pas
se dépêcher de promululer la loi
chercher à renouer le dialogue avec
syndicat et faire en sorte de dire bon
on va d'abord travailler sur d'autres
sujets et puis après on reviendra à la
réforme des retraites salut à tes
proposés il y a eu une main tendue par
les syndicats que j'ai trouvé
extrêmement enfin ouverte en fait la
possibilité de nous
raison
quand même ils ont demandé une médiation
de mettre sur pause de faire enfin ils
ont fait ils ont fait tous les gestes
possibles et imaginables pour permettre
au chef de l'État de s'en sortir sans
être humilié et qu'est-ce que s'est-il
passé en retour un président qui a droit
dans ses bottes chercher à avancer et
qui n'a jamais tenu compte de la vie du
monde syndical c'est quand même de la
folie on est dans une situation où vous
avez quelqu'un qui se retrouve face à
huit Français sur 10 qui lui disent on
ne veut pas et qui dit parce que je suis
Jupiter je continue je ne lâche rien
mais écoutez moi j'ai vu des présidents
de la République qui avait une
légitimité très forte qui avait été très
largement élu ou réelu et qui pourtant
ont fait le choix par sagesse à un
moment donné de retirer leur texte je
pense à François Mitterrand je pense à
Jacques Chirac qui l'un comme l'autre on
fait un moment ce geste là pour
permettre d'apaiser et pour permettre de
maintenir la cohésion d'un pays la
charge principale d'un président de la
République c'est la cohésion du pays ça
n'est pas simplement d'en faire sa tête
ce n'est pas du tout la conception qu'on
devrait avoir de nos institutions de la
République
ça me fait pas plaisir de faire cette
réforme mais elle est nécessaire
si on veut avoir une réforme moi je suis
prêt une réforme des retraites mais pas
celle-là et c'est de cela dont il
fallait discuter comment est-ce qu'on
fait pourquoi est-ce que le capital ne
cotise pas pourquoi est-ce que on a en
fait aujourd'hui des solutions par
dizaines qui ont été toutes repoussées
d'un revers de la main selon même pas
été discutés par le chef de l'État c'est
quand même ça la difficulté bien sûr
qu'on peut réformer les retraites ça a
déjà été fait à plusieurs reprises
simplement pas comme ça et pas en
faisant en sorte que ceux qui seront
demain les victimes de ce système là
sont qui les femmes ou car il y a
hachées les précaires ceux qui ont
consacré à travailler tôt ceux qui ont
les métiers les plus pénibles mais c'est
quand même la réforme la plus injuste
qu'on puisse inventer est-ce que du
réforme d'ailleurs que le Président de
la République avait lui-même condamné
par anticipation à l'époque il était
candidat est-ce que pour vous ce soir ce
sera une allocution pour rien
mais je crains que ce soit une induction
pour rien soit parce qu'ils viennent
nous annoncer que finalement la nuit
pourtant conseil et le week-end aussi il
vient et il retire mais qu'est-ce qu'il
doit dire il doit dire ça pour vous
qu'est-ce que ce soir qu'est-ce qu'il y
a à 20h15 ou 20h30 je ne sais pas fait
que vous seriez content vous diriez ça y
est il a entendu il a eu raison il a
parlé
c'est pas moi qui va être content en
l'occurrence c'est comment est-ce qu'il
fait pour dire aux Français bon ok j'ai
pété un peu poussé loin je reviens et
donc je vous dis ce soir que après avoir
entendu et bien je retire je mets sur
pause je fais en sorte que de suspendre
et permettre d'abord de discuter et puis
après on verra ce qu'on fait et à cette
condition là si il était dans une
situation où il crée les conditions du
dialogue où ils disent ben écoutez ok
j'ai compris et donc cette réforme là
c'est pas possible mais je veux en
discuter avec vous mais là on repart on
discute tout le monde est prêt à
discuter toutes les oppositions seront
prêtes à le faire et en tout cas pour
notre part nous sommes prêts à discuter
d'une réforme juste
Emmanuel Macron a promulgué la loi très
rapidement après la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel est-ce que pour vous la
bataille politique est désormais perdue
non pas du tout on ne baissons pas les
bras et nous n'avons pas dit notre
Daniel dernier mot en fait nous allons
continuer je
j'ai déjà dit ce que le socialiste
ferait et avec eux l'ensemble des forces
de gauche et de l'écologie nous allons
d'abord
aller le premier mai derrière
l'intention syndical faire en sorte que
ce soit un mouvement qui soit un
mouvement historique massif un
raz-de-marée démocratique
montrer que les rapports de France dans
ce pays ensuite nous espérons bien que
le deuxième RIB qui était déposé sera
validé par le Conseil constitutionnel et
donc nous pourrons aller à la rencontre
des Français pour imposer un référendum
au chef de l'État et puis par sécurité
nous avons aussi déposé une proposition
de loi une proposition de loi qui abroge
le passage à 64 ans et donc rien n'est
terminé nous allons continuer et là où
le président
se trompe grossièrement c'est que s'il
pense que ce soit il peut nous dire je
passe à autre chose nous ne sommes pas
prêts à passer à autre chose on va
revenir sur tout ça d'abord une question
de Fabrice vous appelez bien sûr à
manifester massivement le 1er mai à
maintenir une pression syndicale et
politique sur le président de la
République et sur le gouvernement après
et malgré la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel vous êtes en républicain
est-ce que le maintien de cette pression
après cette décision ça n'est pas
remettre quelque part en cause
l'institution
non je vois pas pourquoi moi je n'ai pas
remis j'ai pris acte de la gestion du
Conseil constitutionnel mais c'est parce
que le Conseil valide sur le plan
juridique une loi que cette loi est
devenue bonne par cette seule question
enfin c'est la question juridique n'est
pas la question politique et n'est pas
la question morale n'est pas la question
de la du caractère juste ou pas de la
loi et donc oui il y a aujourd'hui un
problème et il y a une confrontation
entre la légalité et puis la légitimité
pourquoi parce que vous avez aujourd'hui
une loi qui est profondément contestée
rejetée par
l'immense majorité des Français c'est
pas les pièces de l'épaisseur du trait
on n'est pas dans un sur un sujet où il
y a bon c'est pas très bien pour contre
etc non là on est sur un rejet qui est
massif c'est du jamais vu je sais pas
quel est l'autre texte de loi que vous
auriez en mémoire pour lequel un chef de
l'État aurait maintenu alors qu'il y a
quasiment la totalité des Français qui
sont opposés je n'ai pas de je n'ai pas
de je cherche rapidement dans ma mémoire
mais je ne trouve rien de comparable
vous attendiez à cette décision du
Conseil constitutionnel où elle vous a
surpris
j'ai pas que j'étais surpris mais en
tout cas
j'espère que le Conseil adhérait à ce
que nous avions formulé comme remarque
parce qu'il y avait largement de quoi
motiver décision de rejet et donc tout
ça est sujet à interprétation et le
conseil à interprété comme il l'a fait
interpréter ça veut dire quoi ok un
petit peu de politique non ça décision
selon vous ça veut dire que il y a une
marge de l'interprétation et qu'elle a
été utilisée pour venir plutôt du
gouvernement que contester la décision
qu'il avait prise et donc il y a des
interrogations à moi je sais pas si
c'est de la politique en tout cas ce
serait de la mauvaise politique mais je
crois surtout que
je ne veux pas remettre à ce stade en
question une décision qui a été prise
nous avons des règles du jeu qui sont
connues et qui sont celles qu'elles sont
au jour d'aujourd'hui ça n'empêche pas
de réfléchir au moyen de les changer
mais aujourd'hui on ne conteste pas une
institution qui existe et qui est formé
dans les conditions que vous savez donc
pour l'instant c'est ça voilà donc on ne
conteste pas la décision mais ça
n'empêche pas de réfléchir à la façon
dont on pourrait avoir une autre façon
de procéder on pourrait par exemple
avoir demain des juges constitutionnels
qui sont qui doivent être approuvés à la
majorité par les deux assemblées ça
pourrait être une solution par exemple
en tout cas il faut réfléchir à une
façon de rendre totalement indiscutable
ces décisions parce que je vois que
d'autres que moi aujourd'hui contestent
cette décision sur des bases qui sont et
je parle pas de dans le monde politique
je parle même dans le monde des
concessionnalistes et donc si on veut
que on est en fait une institution qui
soit parfaitement respecté le mieux
c'est de faire en sorte que
qu'elle soit incontestable à tout point
de vue aussi qu'il ne faut plus Lomé de
politique au Conseil constitutionnel qui
faut nommer par exemple uniquement des
juristes et je pense qu'il y a c'est
bien qu'il y ait des gens qui ont des
parcours différents mais ça suppose que
ils aient l'adhésion de la majorité
enfin d'une majorité à l'Assemblée au
Sénat pourquoi je dis ça c'est parce que
quand on tire sa légitimité non pas
simplement de celui qui vous a nommé
mais d'assembler différentes et bien on
se comporte de manière plus indépendante
par rapport au pouvoir exécutif et c'est
bien cette question là qui est posée
est-ce que le fait d'avoir à la tête du
Conseil constitutionnel une ancienne
figure du Parti socialiste Laurent
Fabius vous avez donné un espoir non je
pense qu'il se comporte comme un comme
le juge constitutionnel qu'il doit être
et donc qu'il n'y avait pas un attendre
plus de lui que d'un autre il a voilà
quand on est quand on devient dans nos
conseils constitutionnel j'espère que
c'est comme ça qu'on se comporte c'est
que on juge en droit et non pas
simplement en fonction de s'amuser passé
le Conseil fonctionnel qui a donc
invalidé votre première demande de riz
parce qu'il n'y a pas une part de
responsabilité de la gauche est-ce que
vous reconnaissez qu'il était mal écrit
nous avons redéposé un second rythme
c'est bien la preuve que nous avions
conscience du fait que le premier
pouvait être rotoqué et nous allons voir
si le second lait et le second de mon
point de vue il est parfaitement
admissible et il serait assez curieux
que le Conseil constitutionnel
l'invalide alors qu'il tient compte des
remarques qui ont été faites dans
l'audition que nous représentants sont
allés faire devant le conseil et les
questions qui ont été posées sur le
premier RIP ont permis de modifier en
fait le second et donc de faire en sorte
que nous répondions aux attentes du
conseil donc on verra bien
on se doutait qu'il le serait
pas qu'il était mal écrit c'est qu'en
tout cas il correspondait pas au canon
de beauté du Conseil constitutionnel là
aussi d'interprétation qui est très
forte et donc comme les textes sont
flous et bien ça laisse aussi une grosse
mage interprétation et cette marge il
faut la réduire et donc j'espère bien
que le deuxième RIB sera adopté et que
nous ferons ensuite aller chercher les
4,7 millions de signatures et imposées
au chef de l'État un référendum sauf que
ça va prendre du temps même si les
valider le 3 mai ensuite si vous avez 9
mois pour chercher les signatures
ensuite il y a 6 mois pour que le texte
soit examiné est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
en train de donner de faux espoirs aux
Français mais je ne cherche pas à donner
de l'espoir je cherche à mener une
action on n'a pas à espérer on n'avait
pas en train d'attendre le grand soir on
est en train de se dire que il y a
encore des moyens d'avancer de faire
plier le gouvernement et donc ça suppose
d'agir au fur et à mesure et donc de
chercher tous les moyens qui la mettent
d'agir et
la réalité politique c'est que il est
très difficile pour un gouvernant quel
qu'il soit de gouverner contre son
propre peuple et donc nous devons le
matérialiser par des manifestations par
un rythme éventuellement qui permet
d'aller chercher des signatures par une
voie des propositions de loi que nous
déposons et qui permettent de revenir
sur la loi qui a été votée tout ça c'est
de la politique c'est une façon de dire
mais non on ne passe pas à la séquence
suivante et donc on a arrêté
on arrête tout et on se met on reste sur
le sujet pour empêcher le chef de l'État
de faire ce qu'il veut parce que il y a
un bon truc
je l'espère je ferai tout pour ça moi
encore une fois je n'espère pas j'agis
pour que ça marche parce que si jamais
vous enfin si vous réussissez à avoir
les 4,8 millions de signatures le texte
peut être le Parlement pardon peut se
saisir du texte et il y a quand même de
grandes chances que le Sénat le rejette
oui je sais bien mais il y a un fait
politique si vous avez 4,7 millions de
signatures qui sont déposées c'est un
fait politique majeur et en réalité
juridiquement là encore il est possible
de contourner mais est-ce qu'il est
possible politiquement de le faire je ne
le crois pas je pense qu'à un moment
soit il y a le retrait soit il y a
référendum mais on ne peut pas s'asseoir
comme ça sur des millions de gens qui
manifestent par leur signature par leur
engagement leur volonté d'un référendum
le retrait ça paraît compliqué
maintenant que la loi est promulguée
mais vous avez déposé vous allez déposer
vous allez me dire une proposition pour
abroger cette réforme vous allez la
déposer quand vous allez la déposer à
l'Assemblée nationale au Sénat c'est
uniquement le Parti socialiste ou c'est
avec la nuque nous avons proposé de le
faire et donc nous allons voir c'est qui
est prêt à s'y ajouter et ensuite nous
déposerons dans les deux assemblées dans
les deux assemblées et pour le moment
c'est uniquement le PS la nuque vous a
pas une proposition que nous avons faite
et nous n'avons pas eu de rencontres
depuis donc on verra ce qu'il en est
demain puisque c'est de mardi que nous
nous réunissions mais vous souhaitez que
la nups
de force possible dès les signatures et
montrer que là aussi il y a des gens qui
sont prêts à revenir à ne pas laisser
passer et cette volonté se manifeste par
tout moyen vous la déposerez quand le
plus rapidement possible
vous préparez également une notion de
censure
c'est une discussion nous devons avoir
demain puisqu'elle est proposée par
certains moi je souhaite que nous
puissions aller à la motion à une seule
condition c'est qu'elle permet de
conforter un rapport de force à minima
qui était celui de la dernière motion de
censure si c'est une motion qui est une
motion qui est moins bien votée ça
affaiblirait au contraire la côte
station donc je souhaite qu'on reste là
donc c'est-à-dire vous êtes obligé de
discuter avec le groupe yote oui par
exemple mais enfin j'attends de voir
quelles sont les réactions dans la dans
au Parlement et ensuite on verra donc
c'est pas sûr
ça suppose comme toujours en fait je
suis pas palovien donc j'essaye de
réfléchir à chaque fois quand on avance
l'évoquer la séquence suivante vous ne
voulez pas passer Marine Le Pen elle
manifestement souhaitait y passer
puisque elle demandait ce weekend donc
elle réitérer d'ailleurs une dissolution
de l'Assemblée nationale vous y verriez
un intérêt
Marine Le Pen pour savoir ce que je
pense donc moi j'ai toujours dit la même
chose j'ai toujours dit que quand on a
une situation d'impasse et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui et bien il faut revenir
devant le peuple souvent c'est de deux
façons soit le référendum soit la
dissolution et une solution comme
l'autre me convient parfaitement je
souhaite que avec le risque comporte une
dissolution justement d'offrir plus de
sièges au rassemblement national mais
dans tout dans tout votre risque moi je
ne peux pas préjugé de ce que disent les
Français avant même qu'ils aient voté
mais je suis un démocrate aussi et donc
je me plie à la décision des Françaises
et des Français si les Français demain
disaient par l'avoir référendaire qu'ils
sont favorables au texte les 64 ans et
bien je me plairai alors décision je ne
suis pas contrairement Emmanuel Macron
je ne pense pas avoir raison contre les
Français et un moment où c'est eux qui
choisissent c'est en tout cas c'est
comme ça que nous avons défini la
démocratie donc si demain les Français
choisissent de conduire une majorité qui
n'est pas celle que je souhaite je m'y
plie si demain les Français souhaitent
cette réforme à 64 ans je m'y plie aussi
simplement comme je lis comme vous les
sondages et comme j'écoute les Français
je me dis que j'ai plus de chance que
Emmanuel Macron de l'emporter comment
vous expliquer que c'est ce soit en tout
cas selon les sondages plus le
rassemblement national que la gauche qui
tire profite cette séquence
c'est assez simple à comprendre en fait
quand vous avez aujourd'hui des gens qui
manifestent derrière l'intentace
syndicale et qui se disent mais c'est
fou quand même on est des millions en
manifestés et les sondages attestent le
fait que c'est pas seulement les gens
dans la rue c'est en fait une immense
majorité et que malgré tout il ne se
passe rien que le chef de l'État
continue à avancer comme si seul il
pouvait décider pour tous forcément il y
a des gens qui dans leur colère se
disent finalement il faut être forte il
faut tout basculer et il faut peut-être
faire bouger les lignes en allant voter
jusqu'à l'extrême droite mais ça c'est
responsabilité du chef de l'État c'est
lui qui nourrit au fur et à mesure ce
sentiment de colère de ressentiment et
avec des gens qui soient pas dans
l'abstention considère qu'il y a plus
rien à faire soit considère que il faut
choisir le pire parce que c'est
peut-être la seule façon de faire bouger
les choses et donc c'est une
responsabilité immense que le chef de
l'État prend quand il n'écoute pas des
millions de gens qui viennent lui dire
nous ne voulons pas de cette réforme
mais pour vous c'est le chef de l'État
il n'y a pas d'échec de la stratégie de
la gauche
la gauche qu'est-ce qu'elle fait elle se
bat depuis des mois pour dire cette
réforme on en veut pas donc il peut y
avoir des désaccords sur des points sur
des sujets tactiques au Sénat à
l'Assemblée etc enfin c'est dérisoire
par rapport à la question de fond et les
Français s'intéressent assez peu la
procédure parlementaire ce qui est
intéressant c'est de savoir quel est le
résultat ils disent on ne veut pas être
réformes et votre chef de l'État qui dit
ça m'est égal vous n'êtes rien et bien
écoutez c'est ça qu'il est c'est ça qui
crée du dégoût qui crée du désœuvrement
et c'est ça qui crée aussi effectivement
parfois des gens qui filent à l'extrême
droite en se disant bah au moins comme
ça on casse tout une gauche qui tente de
s'organiser poursuivre sa organisation
dans le cadre de la nupesse une UPS qui
continue de diviser y compris dans votre
camp ou Parti socialiste qui pose des
questions au PC ça vous a pas échappé à
Marseille est-ce que le modèle de la
nups n'a pas atteint ses limites
je sais pas ce que vous appelez ces
limites si la question c'est est-ce que
la nupesse l'a emporté au mois de juin
la réponse c'est non donc effectivement
ça suppose que on se pose des questions
et surtout qu'on cherche à s'élargir on
ne peut pas se replier tous les partis
quand je vois enfin je comprends que
dans chaque partie il y a des gens qui
veulent se replier sur eux-mêmes mais
qui considère que
quand plus on est petit plus on est
grand mais non en fait plus on est petit
plus on est petit et donc ça suppose de
se dire qu'il y a un socle le socle
c'est ce que nous avons construit au
mois de juin mais ça ne suffit pas et
donc il faut s'élargir maintenant aux
françaises et aux Français qui se sont
engagés dans cette dans le combat contre
la réforme des retraites aller chercher
celles et ceux qui en société civile
organisée ou pas et bien son prêt
avancer avec nous faire en sorte que ce
soit non pas un plafond mais un plancher
la nups et donc c'est le socle à partir
de là on avance on construit on
construit des étages supérieurs qui
permettent à un moment d'arriver une
majorité
parce que 30% des voix pour la gauche à
l'élection présidentielle et puis
ensuite on Éditions Législatives ça ne
suffit pas ça suppose aller plus loin y
compris dans le cas des européennes
mais dans toutes les ils sont partisans
parce que là il y a pas de majorité à
aller chercher puisque c'est une
élection à la proportionnelle et que
c'est dans une assemblée qui est bien
plus large que la France et qui est
européenne donc cette un peu différent
mais pour toutes les autres érections
oui bien sûr ça suppose deux chercher en
fait une majorité est-ce qu'il faut des
listes communes ou pas hier manuel
Bompard a lancé un appel à la gauche en
disant souhaiter des listes communes
quitte à se ranger derrière un candidat
écolo c'est aussi votre avis mais c'est
une c'est une possibilité qui a été
émise depuis longtemps par la fi moi
j'ai toujours répondu la même chose ça
n'est pas en fait
l'alliance qui fait le projet c'est le
projet qui va faire l'Alliance et donc
ça suppose que sur la question
européenne il y a des convergences qui
soient des convergences fortes qui
permettent d'avancer ce qui est pas le
cas aujourd'hui donc ça veut dire que je
peux pas y avoir de disponible vous avez
compris ce que je disais en fait il y a
quand on a un projet qui est différent
il suppose en fait des disques
différentes surtout dans un scrutin et
proportionnel si au contraire on a des
projets qui convergent là il y a aucune
justification à faire différemment
surtout que les écolos sont opposés à
une liste commune vous qu'est-ce comment
ça va se passer est-ce que vous referez
l'attelage avec place publique ou est-ce
qu'il y aura une liste socialiste
socialiste ce sera débattu dans la
partie socialiste et donc moi je
souhaite effectivement qu'on continue à
travailler avec des gens qui ont fait le
boulot qui ont montré aussi leurs
capacité à entraîner sur de grands
sujets l'ensemble de l'opinion publique
à la fois national et même parfois
européenne et donc
sa place et
ce n'est pas simplement l'amitié qui
parle c'est aussi
le la reconnaissance d'un travail qui a
été fort bien accompli pendant tout ce
temps hier Stéphane c'est journal patron
de renaissance disait ceci c'est dommage
que le PS est le groupe socialiste soit
la remorque de LFI parce que ce n'est
pas leur identité politique que lui
dites-vous je rigole
franchement est-ce que en fait comment
s'appelle Stéphane séjourné
c'est lui qui donne des leçons Obs parce
qu'il doit faire ou pas alors je sais
bien que en général tous ceux qui ont un
jour trahi leur famille d'origine trouve
une justification très facile au fait
que nous ayons bâti une alliance avec
l'ensemble des forces de gauche ça donne
bonne conscience ils sont heureux comme
ça en fait ça leur dit ça les lave de
tous leurs péchés originels croient-il
mais la réalité c'est que même bien
avant la nuit pêche ils avaient déjà
trahi depuis longtemps et donc ils n'ont
aucune leçon de gauche à donner à qui
que ce soit quand on est en fait dans le
parti qui soutient 64 ans qui soutient
la baisse des allocations chômage qui
soutient la répression
d'un des migrants etc enfin je ne sais
pas ce qu'il est lient encore à leur
passé et donc je crois que
c'est voilà c'est
pour vous
de la
la mage présidentielle du côté de la
gauche parce que certains de la gauche
journée qui est patron de renaissance
est encore à gauche moi je veux bien
mais la régie à des gens qui sont à
gauche
vous me suggérez en fait de dire quoi
s'élargir à au milieu du sobp la réponse
elle est nettement non effectivement
mais c'est pas enfin moi je suis pas
dans un truc d'appareil je suis un truc
qui permet de dire à des gens qui ont
voté pour Emmanuel Macron et qui ont
pensé que c'était lui le meilleur
barrage à l'extrême droite qui ont pensé
que il allait mener peut-être une
politique qui serait équilibrée entre la
droite et la gauche et qui sont très
déçus aujourd'hui j'en vois plein qui
dans la rue me disent moi j'ai voté
manuel Macron mais ça je ne leur ferai
pas bon et ben effectivement ces gens là
il faut le s'élargir à eux il faut leur
dire ben écoutez il y a une place pour
vous et nous allons travailler ensemble
il s'agit pas de faire des des huit clos
dans chaque partie mais non nous allons
nous ouvrir à la toutes celles et ceux
qui veulent avancer avec nous
et puis après on verra quels sont ceux
qui sont prêts à nous rejoindre mais
je vais il y a eu dans la dernière des
statue des gens qui ont quitté la
République en marche je pense à des gens
qui sont chez les écologistes avec
orientation je pense à Emilie Cariou qui
a rejoint la direction du PS et qui est
venu nous rejoindre et qui s'occupe
aujourd'hui d'économie et de finances
dans notre direction pourquoi l'a-t-elle
fait parce qu'à un moment elle s'est
rendu compte qu'elle faisait fausse
route avec des gens dont elle avait
sincèrement cru qu'il pouvait être dans
une forme d'équilibre qui lui convenait
cette équilibre elle ne l'a pas trouvé
donc elle a fait la presse
responsabilité elle est partie et moi
c'est des gens comme ça qui
m'intéressent c'est des gens qui à un
moment se disent bon on a fait fausse
route et qui sont capables de le
reconnaître et d'avancer et ensuite
d'approuver le rassemblement de la
gauche et de l'écologie parce qu'il est
le seul qui va mettre d'engager demain
les ruptures nécessaires moi je ne veux
pas qu'on ait une coalition qui serait
simplement là pour coller des rustines
je veux une coalition qui se cadavre
d'engager le changement le changement
démocratique le changement écologique le
changement social voilà c'est ça qu'on a
le changement féministe comme tous ces
éléments là suppose une majorité large
une majorité confortable qui permet
demain d'assumer de grandes
transformations et donc ça suppose aller
chercher plus loin sur ce qui se passe
au sein de votre partie est-ce que le
résultat de la législative en arrière ou
la dissidente socialiste a battu la
candidate de la nuque que vous soutenez
vous affaibli au sein du Parti
socialiste
j'aime beaucoup l'Ariège et j'aime
beaucoup les conclusions qu'on tire
d'une d'une légative partielle mais vous
savez qu'hier soir il y a eu des
élections législatives partielles encore
il y a un candidat donc de génération et
qui appartient à la génération nups qui
a été élu à
67%, est-ce que ce matin vous me
demandez si nous devrions tous être
confortés ou tous rejoindre le mouvement
génération parce qu'il serait l'avenir
de la gauche
de votre partie
mais est-ce que vous tirez des
conclusions identiques de toutes les
partiels vous avez une élection
partielle comme son nom l'indique elle
est partielle dans une circonscription
qu'il est une des conséquences
nationales des deux meilleures
circonscriptions pour la gauche en
France c'est une sécrétion
exceptionnelle puisque vous avez même
deux candidats de gauche au second tour
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
situation est reproductible par tout
ailleurs en France c'est pas vrai en
fait la réalité c'est que en général
c'est même compliqué pour un candidat de
gauche être second tour donc si vous
faites en sorte de généraliser cette
situation en Ariège vous vous trompez et
donc ça ne marche pas voilà donc
essayons de de dresser dans une forme de
logique je vois bien qu'il y a des tas
de gens qui ont intérêt à dissoudre la
coalition et je vois bien que toute la
presse de droite qui a fait les gorges
chaudes de cette circonscription de
l'Ariège comme s'il s'agissait en fait
d'une élection générale mais pourquoi le
Frontier des gens qui ont il y a des
gens qui ont intérêt à créer la crédité
cette thèse que la gauche se fragmente
plus elle est forte mais c'est faux plus
la gauche se fragmente moins elle est
forte et donc depuis toujours et depuis
Jean Jaurès la bataille pour l'unité
d'une bataille qui est centrale pourquoi
parce qu'elle est la seule qui permet
d'engager le changement autrement vous
pouvez trouver des majorités de
circonstances qui permettent peut-être
de coller des rustines mais qui ne
permettent jamais je vous ai jamais de
faire les grandes réformes dont nous
avons besoin donc pour vous ça ne doit
pas avoir de conséquences est-ce que
Nicolas Mayer rossignol qui a des
positions souvent divergentes avec vous
peut rester 1er secrétaire délégué mais
moi ça m'est égal et les délégués
aujourd'hui à rien puisque il a refusé
tout ce qu'on lui a proposé on l'a
croisé de travailler sur les européennes
il a refusé enfin il a proposé de faire
une majorité ensemble il n'en veut pas
bon bah donc il continue son chemin moi
je ne suis pas là pour faire la police
je suis un démocrate ils disent qu'il
veut mais en tout cas il y a une ligne
aujourd'hui c'est une ligne qui est une
ligne claire c'est une ligne de
rassemblement c'est une ligne aussi qui
permet la transformation sociale moi je
suis dans un parti de transformation je
ne suis pas un parti comme je viens de
le dire qui est juste là pour coller des
rustines pour faire un peu mieux que
voisin voilà un dernier mot rapidement
sur un autre sujet dans l'affaire du
fond Marianne contre le séparatisme il y
a une enquête de Marianne et France 2
qui a révélé une utilisation opaque de
ce fond créé par Marlène Schiappa en
2021 Claude Raynal le président
socialiste de la commission des finances
demande au gouvernement de lui
transmettre l'ensemble des documents
concernant ce fond d'ici mercredi
qu'attendez-vous de cette initiative
tout et Claude Raynal a eu raison de le
faire et les pouvoirs qui lui sont
conférés par la présidence donc de la
question des finances doivent vous
permettre d'accéder à ces documents
c'est un scandale total d'avoir
aujourd'hui une ministre qui en fait a
utilisé la mémoire de Samuel Paty pour
en faire un instrument de politicien au
service de ses propres amis et donc oui
il y a un sujet et j'espère que y
compris cette ministre reviendra y
répondre et même dans Playboy elle peut
venir expliquer ce qu'elle a fait de
l'argent parce que c'est quand même un
sujet incroyable que d'instrumentaliser
à ce point le sujet grave qui est celui
donc du séparatisme qu'elle avait mis en
avant donc sur lesquels sur lequel elle
s'est fait un nom pour ensuite
l'utiliser l'instrumentaliser à des fins
purement politiciennes merci Merci à
VOUS Olivier fort notre invité merci
Fabrice merci et on passe au club des
territoires